Anyone else not enjoy going out anymore,
like I'll have girlfriends call me up and say,
“hey girl,
what are you doing this weekend?”
I'm like nothing
They’re like “you wanna do something?”
Not really, in fact,
that's the last thing I wanna do,
leave my house?
why why would I do that?
maybe it's because my social battery as an adult is now non existent
but I like staying home.
Maybe I’m depressed?
No, that's not depression.
I think it's because I don't like anyone else
besides my fiance and select close friends.
if I go outside,
I see other people and people I don't know are scary.
maybe that's why?
I don't I really don't know?
but honestly I'm content chilling at home!